الى واشنطن بحثا عن اسلحه جديده وقد حصل
عليها صواريخ للدفاع الجوي وذخيره
لمنظومات صاروخيه واسلحه مضاده للدبابات
لكن بدون تزويدها في المرحله الراهنه
بصواريخ بعيده المدى تطالب بها غير ان
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن طمئن زيلينسكي
بدعم الولايات المتحده المستمر لاوكرانيا
ستواصل الولايات المتحده الوقوف الى
جانبكم لقد وافقت اليوم على الدفعه
الثانيه من المساعدات الاوكرانيا بما في
ذلك المدفعيه والذخيره والاسلحه المضاده
للدبابات سيتم تسليم اول دبابات ابرمز
الامريكيه الى اوكرانيا الاسبوع المقبل
اشكر الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والسيده
الرئيس على حزمه المساعده الجديده
لاوكرانيا انها مساعده هائله
شكرا جزيلا هو بالضبط ما يحتاجه جنودنا
اليوم
قبل هذا كان الرئيس الاوكراني قد التقى
بكبار مسؤول الدفاع والسياسيين من كلا
الحزبين لكنه لم يلقى نفس الترحيب الذي
حظي به خلال زيارته الاولى في كانون الاول
ديسمبر رغم ذلك القى كلمه حملت نبره
التحذير كما اكده بعض النواب
كانت هناك جمله واحده تلخص كل شيء وانا
اقتبس حرفيا ما جاء فيها قال السيد
زيلينسكي اذا لم نحصل على المساعدات فسوف
نخسر الحرب هذا اقتباس منه
لكن مشرعون جمهوريون هددوا بعرقله اقرار
حزمه مساعدات جديده مقدره باربعه وعشرين
مليار دولار فيما قال الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن انه يعول على حكمه الكونجرس
الامريكي